i got a problem with french fries  at a steakhouse  i don't care how fancy you want to make  them it's still french fries  to me when you add a steak house no more  french fries  get them out of there  get the french fries out of the  steakhouse buy  it's the same reason why you don't get a  baked potato at mcdonald's  you don't go to yeah let me get the the  big mac with the orange soda and the  baked potato with all the tremens no  because baked potato is fancy potato  french fries is  that's riff raff that's for like you  know that's fast food be an adult and  get a baked potato stop getting french  fries at a steak house i hate to see  people with uh a 70 steak all kinds of  tomahawks and and all this kind of stuff  you do not pair that with french fries  like a animal